What is going on in London that involves the CIA and a terrorist strike?
MI5 is committing every available asset to this.
I think I've unlocked a source for a terrorist.
I have an eye for talent.
I trained you in the country's interest.
What's your status?
In danger.
Someone is hunting me.
I'm thinking I'm the only friend you've got.
Our prisoner has gone to ground and I do not intend to let him stay there.
Let the past go or it's gonna get in the way when it counts.
Global viruses are the biggest threat to mankind,...
...each one a ticking bomb.
Incubation is fast.
Start the timers.
He has to be stopped.
The meet is on.
Three hours.
When it's armed, you've got five minutes.
Tell me how to stop it.
You can't.
Abort! Abort!
In a different world, it doesn't come to this.
Who is the target?
There's no time for guessing.